In this video, we'll see how to
build a CART model in R. Let's
start by reading in the
data file "stevens.csv".
We'll call our
data frame stevens
and use the read.csv function
to read in the data file
"stevens.csv".
Remember to navigate
to the directory
on your computer containing
the file "stevens.csv" first.
Now, let's take a look at our
data using the str function.
We have 566 observations,
or Supreme Court cases,
and nine different variables.
Docket is just a unique
identifier for each case,
and Term is the
year of the case.
Then we have our six independent
variables: the circuit
court of origin, the
issue area of the case,
the type of petitioner, the type
of respondent, the lower court
direction, and whether or
not the petitioner argued
that a law or practice
was unconstitutional.
The last variable is
our dependent variable,
whether or not
Justice Stevens voted
to reverse the case: 1 for
reverse, and 0 for affirm.
Now before building
models, we need
to split our data into a
training set and a testing set.
We'll do this using the
sample.split function,
like we did last week
for logistic regression.
First, we need to load
the package caTools
with library(caTools).
Now, so that we all get the same
split, we need to set the seed.
Remember that this can be
any number, as long as we all
use the same number.
Let's set the seed to 3000.
Now, let's create our split.
We'll call it spl, and we'll
use the sample.split function,
where the first argument needs
to be our outcome variable,
stevens$Reverse, and then
the second argument is
the SplitRatio, or the
percentage of data that we want
to put in the training set.
In this case, we'll put 70% of
the data in the training set.
Now, let's create our
training and testing
sets using the subset function.
We'll call our
training set Train,
and we'll take a
subset of stevens,
only taking the observations
for which spl is equal to TRUE.
We'll call our testing
set Test, and here
take a subset of
stevens, but this time,
taking the observations for
which spl is equal to FALSE.
Now, we're ready to
build our CART model.
First we need to
install and load
the rpart package and the
rpart plotting package.
Remember that to
install a new package,
we use the
install.packages function,
and then in
parentheses and quotes,
give the name of the
package we want to install.
In this case, rpart.
After you hit
Enter, a CRAN mirror
should pop up asking you to
pick a location near you.
Go ahead and pick the
appropriate location.
In my case, I'll
pick Pennsylvania
in the United
States, and hit OK.
You should see some
lines run your R Console,
and then, when you're back
to the blinking cursor,
load the package
with library(rpart).
Now, let's install the
package rpart.plot.
Again, some lines should
run in your R Console,
and when you're back
to the blinking cursor,
load the package with
library(rpart.plot).
Now we can create our CART
model using the rpart function.
We'll call our
model StevensTree,
and we'll use the
rpart function, where
the first argument is the
same as if we were building
a linear or logistic
regression model.
We give our dependent
variable-- in our case,
Reverse-- followed
by a tilde sign,
and then the
independent variables
separated by plus signs.
So Circuit + Issue +
Petitioner + Respondent
+ LowerCourt + Unconst.
We also need to
give our data set
that should be used to build
our model, which in our case
is Train.
Now we'll give two
additional arguments here.
The first one is
method = "class".
This tells rpart to build a
classification tree, instead of
a regression tree.
You'll see how we can create
regression trees in recitation.
The last argument we'll
give is minbucket = 25.
This limits the tree
so that it doesn't
overfit to our training set.
We selected a
value of 25, but we
could pick a smaller
or larger value.
We'll see another way to limit
the tree later in this lecture.
Now let's plot our tree
using the prp function,
where the only argument is the
name of our model, StevensTree.
You should see the tree pop
up in the graphics window.
The first split of our
tree is whether or not
the lower court
decision is liberal.
If it is, then we move
to the left in the tree.
And we check the respondent.
If the respondent is a criminal
defendant, injured person,
politician, state,
or the United States,
we predict 0, or affirm.
You can see here that the
prp function abbreviates
the values of the
independent variables.
If you're not sure what
the abbreviations are,
you could create a
table of the variable
to see all of the
possible values.
prp will select
the abbreviation so
that they're uniquely
identifiable.
So if you made a
table, you could
see that CRI stands
for criminal defendant,
INJ stands for
injured person, etc.
So now moving on in our tree,
if the respondent is not
one of these types, we
move on to the next split,
and we check the petitioner.
If the petitioner is a
city, employee, employer,
government official,
or politician,
then we predict 0, or affirm.
If not, then we check the
circuit court of origin.
If it's the 10th, 1st, 3rd,
4th, DC or Federal Court,
then we predict 0.
Otherwise, we predict
1, or reverse.
We can repeat this same process
on the other side of the tree
if the lower court
decision is not liberal.
Comparing this to a
logistic regression model,
we can see that it's
very interpretable.
A CART tree is a series
of decision rules
which can easily be explained.
Now let's see how
well our CART model
does at making predictions
for the test set.
So back in our R Console,
we'll call our predictions
PredictCART, and we'll use
the predict function, where
the first argument is the name
of our model, StevensTree.
The second argument
is the new data
we want to make
predictions for, Test.
And we'll add a third argument
here, which is type = "class".
We need to give this argument
when making predictions
for our CART model if we want
the majority class predictions.
This is like using
a threshold of 0.5.
We'll see in a few minutes how
we can leave this argument out
and still get probabilities
from our CART model.
Now let's compute the
accuracy of our model
by building a confusion matrix.
So we'll use the table function,
and first give the true outcome
values-- Test$Reverse, and then
our predictions, PredictCART.
To compute the accuracy,
we need to add up
the observations we got
correct, 41 plus 71, divided
by the total number of
observations in the table,
or the total number of
observations in our test set.
So the accuracy of our
CART model is 0.659.
If you were to build a
logistic regression model,
you would get an
accuracy of 0.665
and a baseline model
that always predicts
Reverse, the most
common outcome,
has an accuracy of 0.547.
So our CART model significantly
beats the baseline
and is competitive with
logistic regression.
It's also much
more interpretable
than a logistic
regression model would be.
Lastly, to evaluate our model,
let's generate an ROC curve
for our CART model
using the ROCR package.
First, we need to load the
package with the library
function, and then we need to
generate our predictions again,
this time without the
type = "class" argument.
We'll call them
PredictROC, and we'll
use the predict
function, giving just
as the two arguments
StevensTree and newdata = Test.
Let's take a look
at what this looks
like by just typing
PredictROC and hitting Enter.
For each observation
in the test set,
it gives two numbers
which can be thought
of as the probability
of outcome 0
and the probability
of outcome 1.
More concretely, each
test set observation
is classified into a subset,
or bucket, of our CART tree.
These numbers give the
percentage of training
set data in that
subset with outcome 0
and the percentage of
data in the training set
in that subset with outcome 1.
We'll use the second
column as our probabilities
to generate an ROC curve.
So just like we did last
week for logistic regression,
we'll start by using
the prediction function.
We'll call the output pred,
and then use prediction,
where the first argument is the
second column of PredictROC,
which we can access
with square brackets,
and the second argument is
the true outcome values,
Test$Reverse.
Now we need to use the
performance function, where
the first argument is the
outcome of the prediction
function, and then
the next two arguments
are true positive rate and
false positive rate, what
we want on the x and
y-axes of our ROC curve.
Now we can just plot our ROC
curve by typing plot(perf).
If you switch back to
your graphics window,
you should see the ROC
curve for our model.
In the next quick
question, we'll
ask you to compute the
test set AUC of this model.